To see what the RAID 0
reliability looks like,
let's assume that f is a failure
rate for a single disk.
A failure rate is really how
many failures do we expect for
a single working disk
to have in a second.
Obviously, this number
will be extremely small.
Usually we can assume that the failure
rate is constant over time,
that is, every second, if the desk is
working at the beginning of the second,
it has the same failure
rate during that second.
For a single disk then, the MTTF,
the mean time to failure,
will be 1 over f.
So, for example, if the disk has one
millionth of a failure per second,
then the MTTF will be 1 million seconds.
For disks, the entity f is also
sometimes called mean time
to data loss, or how long until
we lose some data on this disk.
And for a single disk,
the mean time to data loss
is the same as the MTTF of one disk.
Now, let's look at what happens when we
have N such disks in
a RAID 0 configuration.
It turns out that the failure
rate when we have N working disks
is equal to N times
the failure rate of one disk.
This is because, for
example, if we can expect one millionth
of a failure per working disk per second
then we can expect one failure per
million working disks per second.
So if we start the second
with a million working disks,
chances are that one of them
will fail during the second.
If we start the second with
half a million working disks,
on average half of a single disk
will fail per second, and so on.
It also turns out that the mean time to
the first failure among N working disks
has the same distribution as the first
failure for the single disk, so
we get that MTTF for
N disks in a RAID 0 configuration,
where MTTF is really the mean
time to data loss in this case,
is equal to the MTTF of
one disk divided by N.
So if you have two disks,
the MTTF of the RAID 0 array with two
disks will be half of
the MTTF of a single disk.
A single disk typically
will have the MTTF
on the order of ten-ish
years to maybe 100 years.
So if we have too many disks in a raid
zero configuration, we can reduce
the MTTF, so the average disk will not
fail in the five or six years that we
actually end up using it, but if we have
two or three or four such disks then we
can expect the array to fail at least
once until we actually get rid of it.